ladder with Crowder studios is protected
exclusively by Walther in Upper and not
gay Jarrod the Winter Olympics can
inspire anyone who want to get in shape
but you don't have to wait for that
fresh coat of powder that's right your
local skating rink is a great place to
stay fit and have fun today we're going
to be learning how to figure skate I'm
uncomfortable on the ice and always
remember as with any new athletic
endeavor safety first
now before you move on to any advanced
tricks it's important to take a few laps
and stretch those cold muscles
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
down home body break with steven crowder
and not gay jerry sponsored by mud club
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
what's that story when all you had to
worry about were white guy gangs with
short blades great show tonight
huge show unbelievable so we have Nigel
Faraj of course the pimp pimp from from
the UK the West mr. Lynch Big Daddy
we have stefan molyneux on KD I think we
have Owen Benjamin a little ditty from
Owen Benjamin and we have some we have
some information to get to Big Joe Neal
some really big show producing with me
in video studio as always it's dear to
his neck a follow him on Twitter and
knock a jeer and me it s Crowder with
your comments your thoughts your
photoshop's
we don't love them but will allow them I
fulfilled my legal obligations during
conclusions are we good charger beings
is as authority yes absolutely at G
Morgan Jr simplified wine calm delivered
straight to your door what's the one of
the day one of the days bellicose las
alturas
that look glows that look loose I'm
pretty sure you pronounced that
incorrectly then again what would I
expect trend computer ready for overlays
good evening ready as always he doesn't
seem ready at all it almost seems as
though he is ill-prepared as let me just
boot him up and we'll be talking today
of course quite a bit about the CNN
scripting town halls I know what you're
thinking and you're thinking Illuminati
crisis actors no that's not the
direction we're going what are you doing
there you go do you see this earlier
now could you put his computer did
corner living right there next to water
for no why would you type that room live
on the edge yes but it's not even like a
physical engine sits edge I have watched
him wet himself at the site of a Honda
Cub but then he will take a needless
risk it doesn't even add there's no
reward don't even understand this all
right speaking of affordable Falcon 9
SpaceX is latest expedition finally
launched today and feminists are mad
like this headline from NBC the
patriarchal race to colonize Mars is
another example of male entitlement they
write and I quote it is the same
instinctually and cultural force that
teaches men that everything and everyone
in their line of vision is theirs for
the taking
you know just like walking up to a woman
and grabbing her by the [ __ ] I love how
this this isn't just proof that
yesterday's salon in Slate is today's
NBC I know it's what point do you say
maybe it's not Fringe its NBC front page
headline look as much crab as we gave
him
Elon Musk just put a rocket in space
okay you just mash your fat feminist paw
on a keyboard and hit auto correct did
you mean to say you can't do anything
Elon Musk might have been pushing this
one a little bit it does seem like an
instigator president it's almost like
they should have blurred that and it
only cost you four hundred billion
dollars worth it
just just grab that solar system when
you say when will feminists be mad about
everything oh now yesterday you imagine
landing on the moon was feminists today
back then look at those giant penises
going for man and one giant we say
people kind not a lawyer in dortmund is
now pressing charges over repeat this
comes to us from spend computer from
journalist how do you pronounce this pen
defend computer don't want no no
deutsche welle okay thank you you were
dismissed a lawyer in Dortmund is now
pressing there's pressing charges over
being repeatedly sent Frank pizzas so
far in Dortmund Grohl has received more
than a hundred on Roxas from different
suppliers you know Michael Moore as my
dreams about that but you know what the
movie rights have already been secured
because he's taking the law into his own
hands
the court will wait for an answer if
lieutenant Kendrick didn't place an
order but two meat lovers into my house
then why did his number show up in a
call lock for you no no I didn't order a
large wine now I have requested to be
removed from this delivery please do the
research when I have requested you
lieutenant Kendrick ordered a mountain
you don't have to answer that question
I'll answer the question you want
answers I feel the truth you can't
handle the truth it's a sad statement
our legal system I hope he finds what
he's looking for an angry cow beat up a
British tourist yesterday so that's I'm
female a tourist was left bloodied and
bruised by a ferocious cow which became
angry after this lady sang at a
black-eyed pea song amused by how large
the creature was she jokingly began
singing the popular song popular my
humps my humps my peace now the cow and
I quote unamused by her rapping ha
suddenly charged at her with its horn
most saddened by the story but still
thrilled but their name is finally back
in the news the black-eyed pea this cow
is awesome I'm now v let's look right
there you guys you to forgive yourself
sing around the sing the song should be
dead
I'm trying to be sexy to the cow wasn't
gosh I don't know it does make you the
black-eyed peas it's kind of like I
meant when the first dollars came out
episode 1 everyone now almost a
gazillion it yeah and people loved it I
hated it I always hated the Black Eyed
Peas I've never had I feel vindicated
did you see them was it was Super Bowl
they right a couple years ago it was so
yeah he worst thing I've ever seen it
might it feels like yesterday is still
the ruins are so fresh even Lady Gaga I
was one she did the spider-man yeah she
put on actually a pretty good show it
you could just tell she hadn't balanced
it someone hadn't calibrated it put on a
few pounds do but a carjacker carjacker
story is always fun carjackers by the
way
from Detroit we invented carjacking
you're welcome that's our gift to the
world made his victim drive to Wendy's
on the way to a drug deal this we're
gonna get to CNN in their fake news
Brett angle was charged with felony
aggravated robbery and abduction for
carjacking one with a box cutter seem
self-explanatory he then forced her to
go to an ATM to take out $200 police
then said that the suspect had the woman
drive to a nearby Wendy's and forced her
to buy him something to eat didn't go
dutch then the 84 year old brought him
to a gas station before finally driving
him to a White Castle where he appeared
to be conducting a drug deal
so most upset by the ordeal is White
Castle for finding out that they're not
serving food fit for drug dealers for
them I can attest it's so insulting he
added ten years to his sentence to avoid
White Castle and it wasn't like that
much of an upgrade it wasn't like no no
we're going to Houstons it was Wendy's
there's that much of a discrepancy this
is a guy who's going to prison because
he didn't know what Ober was yeah so
much trouble
Hey different ubers go ooh BRR ex do the
carpool they can't track you know keep
smarter than us we stopped at what we
did when we were driving fishing in new
Texas manly not fun
very odorous but a very distinct oh
tweet me a desk ride if you noticed this
I was talking about us everyone else
learn oh no White Castle it leaves a
distinctive after burn we don't just
mean like oh we like you ate a bunch of
greasy food there's something very
peculiar about White Castle on what it
does to the humanity and this guy was
like I ain't going down and I smell like
hamster cages hey no way we left and
came back so that they could turn on the
fryers
oh that's right if we waited we had two
minutes at White Castle gosh we had
opportunities everywhere made bad
decisions if that were on our record
there's no way we'd be buying a gun a
doctor who denied sex abuse
well this tada doctor has denied sex
abuse from I think Canada by saying his
belly was too big he lost his license
subsequently apparently the excuse
didn't necessarily work so Ontario's
medical regulator they revoked the
lessons of the very dermatologist who
argue that there was no way he had
complaints that he could have possibly
rubbed his
penis against his female patients
particularly their breasts whole area
because of his large reality I'm trying
to be clean here this is the actual
story so his argument was that he
couldn't I couldn't have done it because
I'm because I haven't done push ups and
the panel actually was unable to
conclude after expert examination mind
you whether his penal area actually made
contact with patients so it was
inconclusive because if the gut don't
fit you probably didn't touch her tit
another guilty man gets off can you
believe that
imagine that that's your argument I mean
you just have to have given up on life
yeah it's like you're cornered here's
like uh-uh-uh
no I couldn't have committed sexual
harassment really why is that
because I'm disgusting morbidly obese
have you seen me I have a rectal
dysfunction I'm unattractive and my
belly gets in the way and I would like
to be free to go Your Honor I haven't
seen a penis in years there's no way I
could have done it no way there's no way
imagine in trying to just to prove that
just like those those those poor
infomercials I can't even heard of old
cell phones there's got to be a better
way to commit sexual assault technology
today gotta be away yeah I don't know
what this is a great intro to nigel
farage so here's one thing we're gonna
talk about CNN this is in the news
obviously CPAC is going up by the way no
we're not coming to your CPAC party
everyone's been asking we're not there
no and a lot of people we ate we're
hanging out here and we have our own
lanyards yes exactly we have our own
lanyards we have the VIP plus plus plus
pass who what does that mean free Klean
Kanteen
so uh Florida obviously I don't want to
name the shooter
there was a you've seen the kids who
have been trotted out yeah 17 kids been
trotted out now one kid came out who was
supposed to speak at the town hall and
he said the CNN rejected his Town Hall
question on armed guards and that it
ended up being scripted that's what the
kid said so the message is you know well
please listen to the children giving
well they
why don't the children of the boys shut
that little [ __ ] up please not that one
not that one not that one CNN went as
far as calling the kid a liar
on Twitter they wrote there's absolutely
no truth to this CNN did not provide
script questions for anyone in last
night's Town Hall nor have we ever okay
if you would have said last night's Town
Hall the kid might have been in a pickle
because maybe he didn't save your Google
Doc right maybe he didn't save the
question that you sent him and you could
wiggle out of it but when you say nor
have we ever be yourself Oh a little bit
of a backdoor it's like the first thing
you learn in political science is just
don't speak and absolutely yeah I you
don't but you don't need a conspiracy
for this by the way okay CNN has a long
history of scripting and that's why
they've been catching flack for it that
Don Lemon is all torn up about it no an
actual lemon just a bitter little fruit
Duncan here he's looking old he really
doesn't like that Johnny Mathis he's
just decayed really fast
oh those Don Lemon every way that one
that one will be seen in the Twitter
section so here's your CNN they have a
hit and let's not I don't want to give
the whole crisis actor thing because
that's a conspiracy that you don't you
don't need a conspiracy theory that you
can't prove verifiably beyond all shadow
of a doubt when you have the truth the
truth should be enough CNN has a long
history with this Donna Brazile right
she they shared debate questions Hillary
Clinton campaign while working at Cena
we know that Michelle Malkin revealed a
long time ago she talked about the
systemic problem I think with the CNN
Town Hall's having Democratic operatives
and activist plants as undecided voters
I mean it's it's not really all that out
of the realm of possible when you
consider we did the ant if a thing and
the media just didn't want to pick up on
it at all yeah is this is the lies by
omission right exactly yeah and you had
guys like Chris coma I think I think
spent computer has it I do you have that
do you have that trend computer so this
was okay yeah Romo
yeah the Chris Brown with a CNN boy in
chief except nobody the kid said I
actually went and didn't actually buy
the gun and walked out without filling
any paperwork out but that's what do you
read tweets and he doesn't go back and
correct my story like walked in looked
into it yeah license and he's like
that's I got it
the rate of fire yeah it's like gosh
this is the kind of story that sways
opinion though yeah no exact or Bono's
well it's antigen there's scripting that
has been going on for a long time and
then there are lies by omission that
they don't even realize their inherent
biases we've talked about that with with
what occurs on campus I think some of it
comes out of mouth and I think some of
that comes out of they just don't even
know I think maybe this person who
issued the CNN statement didn't know
about the donna brazile thing didn't
know about candy candy crowley what
happened with Mitt Romney maybe this
person didn't know it was the same
person was bitching that Elon Musk sent
a penis rocket ship in the sky I have no
idea media there's you want to know why
there is no trust in American
institutions which ones you're asking
all of them now it's because of things
like this we have never ever ever ever
ever provided any scripted question
except if you were to ask me if you were
to say hey Steven scripted an interview
with with Nigel Faraj I would say no no
listen
of course now now let me show you I have
a list of questions where I asked Nigel
Farraj what he's doing at CPAC and later
on I'll be asking him those questions
here they are and then we go off-book I
just haven't I would tell you that
that's what happens but I would not say
no no we've never ever ever ever moved
down any questions at all it's just not
true such a lie and the difference is
CNN is having the people the guests
asking the questions scripted yeah so
hosts should be prepared right Chris
Cuomo so they tried out the kids and
this is a conversation
someone corrected me on Twitter today
and and and they were right I said you
know listen of course everyone has the
right to be heard and kids shouldn't be
in charge of making policy decisions
both computer but they said you know
what no not everyone has the right to be
heard I came rember who said this on
Twitter you can tweet me again it s
Crowder I'll try and retweet you because
it was it was insightful they said no
you have the right to speak you don't
have the right to be heard you can't
force somebody to listen so really they
have a right to speak and a complicit
media ensures that everyone is force-fed
what they're talking about kids no I
don't hate these kids I think I think
one of them for sure the one is
definitely a political opportunist he
was tweeting from the school or started
doing the the Instagram video that's why
I just don't like using kids as gimmicks
they do that seat back to they just
bridge I don't like kids being involved
in politics we just try and avoid on
this show so Seth MacFarlane though
tweeted this out this is the narrative
just like Christopher Titus means in the
show don't you care about kids
since they Fraulein tweeted the American
right is terrified of the students of
Marjory Stoneman Douglas high the
students who rapidly turn themselves
into activists after 17 of their fellow
student and teachers were murdered have
become the most visible face of this new
phase of gun debate number conservatives
of limited okay so we're afraid of kids
that says it used to be you don't care
about kids now we're afraid of kids how
many kids have they trotted out how many
kids were at the town hall anywhere from
15 to 20 oh yeah let's let's say 30 tops
what about the other all students at the
high school who haven't been on the news
what about the kids who actively come
out and said hey you know what I'd like
to talk about it I actually disagree
with what some of these kids are saying
I actually think that this is something
that could have been avoided I think
there's some policies that could be
changed for example putting this in the
in the database nationally the next
background check this guy had thirty
nine calls to the house I think shot a
chicken with his gun there have been
other kids no no no no not so fast right
kids with opinions they agree with trot
him on up Steve okay do you tell me this
what what were you know someone there
had to be a grooming process for that of
course coming through who has the
political viewpoint that they want to be
at some point that had to occur that is
the truth now the lie that people run
with unfortunately the crisis actors go
this kid is pay yeah
just put him in a school for years to
lay low until there's a shooting no what
happened is the kid decided he can get
on TV kids get attention just like a kid
who gets a laugh and so it keeps
repeating the stupid joke because he
keeps getting attention that's what
happens with these kids and then they
stutter over their lines and they get
some scripted dialogue that happens in a
lot of these interviews especially with
inarticulate kids who don't understand
the Second Amendment but it's just funny
you tell me this okay
kids with opinions on gun control some
of them weren't even in the same wing of
the high school they're more relevant
then Steven Willeford who killed the
shooter who shot him with his own ar-15
no one wanted to interview Steven
Willeford every night but throws - we
had him on the show we had an exclusive
because no one was calling so you bring
up the girl with the buzz cut you bring
up the girl who looks like the Minority
Report Oracle to yell at Dana lash on a
CNN Town Hall don't hate the girl I'm
just describing what happens why is her
opinion more relevant than Steven
Wolford and by the way why are we you
don't allow a motive
reactive adults to determine policy
certainly not as it relates to human
rights why would you let a child hmm
something always talking funny of us
that leftist they want to trot children
out there because they it's this idea
that you you can't say no to kids the
right like it's like like you know a
little little kid with a little puppy
eyes it's like you can't say no to the
kids right but they don't realize
there's a whole rest of America is like
you know actually I think I think what
the problem is we need to say no to kids
more often say no all the tech know all
the time
you know six-year-old wants a penis oh
yes I would yes but she also wants to
deny you your fundamental right to
self-protection the Second Amendment
would you deny her want yes I would why
do you hate you I don't hate her
I think she's wrong also that one's kind
of stupid doesn't mean I hate kids
some kids are wrong some kids are right
what bothers me is when the left decides
that the only kids who deserve a voice
are those who agree with them friend I
do not believe for a second that there
is not a single person who would go out
there who would counter the narrative
that these joke I mean this happened
after this happened after 9/11 this
happened after it happens after every
channel here's the thing I mean we have
that to overlay send computer from The
Young Turks ology right now this is when
they just look at this do you support a
federal ban an assault weapon 85% no on
The Young Turks to be fair I think they
were probably infiltrated some but it is
the single losingest issue gun control
pretty ly was young even young liberals
that's the one issue will they'll break
ranks right now they are actually very
probably the most Pro firearm pro-second
amendment generation to have come along
in a long time this is removed from
Michael Moore's Bowling for Columbine
this is removed from the assault weapons
ban Act they realized how silly it was
yeah because now they've been educated
and you realize how far away they get
from like the arguments that would
really actually persuade people shank is
just basically thrown on his tweet just
liberal buzzwords of you blamed he said
the person of CPAC blamed everyone but
the guns it's like of course yes exactly
the unlike him an object in this
equation like should we've been blaming
like Haitian families or like maybe it's
some I don't know Peruvian families he
said American families
yeah you know he's out there so out of
touch yeah I was it just did I hate when
the left throws kids into the narrative
member when people were holding up the
signs usually PPAC did I say that they
say that wrong you just find Parenthood
is what I meant sorry yeah remember when
they did that they're holding up the
signs about abortions and it's like a
little five-year-old on the side of the
road why do you why does the left always
co-op children in emotional situations
right to try to make a point every
single time it is an emotional I had
someone say I think it was recently say
like well so you think that you're right
to own us to own an assault weapon is
more important than a woman's right to
control her own body okay hold on a
second let I can do this too
yes I believe that my right and my
wife's right to protect her life and to
protect the life and limb of her family
is more important than the right of a
woman to kill a baby we can play that
game the difference is we don't trot out
kids to make the arguments because we
know the kids don't fully understand
where rights come from kids don't fully
understand what the Constitution is kids
get kids don't fully understand anything
at this point it doesn't mean that you
hate children
if you think they're wrong or you don't
want to listen to them or you don't want
them to determine policy you let us know
in the comments section what you think
about this do you think it's
politicization or do you think it's just
giving kids a platform and letting them
vent is this healthy is it healing I
will say this this is the reason they
are jumping on it right now it is such
an unpopular issue gun control certainly
as proposed by the left by the way it's
not about bomb stocks it's not about
ar-15s will look at their proposal look
at Heller versus DC it is about the
fundamental right to own a firearm
period look at the legally dissenting
opinion saying you don't have a right to
own a gun those were the arguments it
wasn't had nothing to do with
semi-automatic or rate of fire it had to
do with the fundamental right do you
according to the second man have the
right to own a firearm that's what it's
about that's what the policy is about I
don't think 12 year olds should be
determining what that looks like
in the future but we do have to get
going because a very important man Nigel
Suraj coming up and then Stephan
[Music]
whole body brick with steven crowder
and not gay Jared the Winter Olympics
provide us with a time to watch some
sports that we might not otherwise
typically enjoy it also gives some often
underappreciated roles their time to
shine one of the most underappreciated
roles in all of hockey is that of the
goalie many consider him to be the
lifeblood of the team that's why today
knock a Jared will be learning the skill
of goaltending
but as with any new athletic endeavor
safety first
now even more so than some other
athletic endeavors proper safety
equipment when being a goalie and hockey
is key you'll need the proper shin elbow
hand and face protection now the
goaltender has to use all points of his
body as tools to protect the neck from
his feet all the way to the tips of his
hands as any new sport remember to walk
before you run get a feel for the net
your space and make sure that oh my god
[Applause]
[Music]
home body breaks with steven crowder and
not gay jerry sponsored by mud club
library time I only do one per week and
really grateful obvious errors but
longtime sponsor Walther firearms
I can't remem until people say are you
really gonna advertise firearms at this
point absolutely we're certainly not
shying away from them because they
haven't shied away from us listen you've
heard me talk about their firearms
before we want them to be a sponsor for
a long time before they did come to the
show because we like their stuff love
their stuff I used to be a revolver guy
a lever-action you saw if you're going
semi-automatic with a pistol as far as I
guess obviously rebuff
let's not even get to that conversation
or a caliber war but if we're going to
go with a pistol like this I really I
can't recommend them highly enough so
you've heard me talk about them right
I'm really excited I have a new product
I said if you're gonna get one firearm
for concealed carry this is when you get
the Walther pp s okay that's these are
all unloaded by the way we take proper
precautions single stack really thin
really easy to conceal if we can have
one firearm particularly if you're big
if you just want one for your house you
want a handgun as opposed to a shotgun
rifle the Walther PPQ Google right now
just Walther PPQ review you can't find a
negative one it's universally agreed
upon it has the smoothest trigger which
makes it super easy to fire where we
played horse yeah the shooting range
yeah we went ahead and brand necks next
to it and we quickly did so if you're
gonna get one home that if you're gonna
get one to carry that now if you're only
gonna get one period that's what their
new product is for I'm really excited
about it here let me show you unloaded
okay there you go see it can they see on
the camera I hope so get that close okay
oh yeah all right there you go this is
the Walther PPQ subcompact so this is
actually a double stack it's right
between the two as you can see it's
smaller than the full-sized ppq not
quite as small as this one but it's
really small it's really easy to conceal
in fact actually depending on which
magazine configuration you have it is
smaller exactly yeah exactly this is
actually smaller not as far as width but
basically gonna get one this has a 10 +
7 11 round capacity you get the trigger
that you get them to ppq you have all
the great qualities and it's just again
it's a jack-of-all-trades at that point
if you're only going to get one this is
one recommend you get and here's another
reason why here really easy to conceal I
just headed a holster I've had it all
show or you can change it out I have
this
again empty let's just make sure you see
empty okay change it out with a cuff you
can see this that's a full size magazine
and now you've got 15 plus 1 in that
same firearm so it has the capacity
saying this is of this size and it's
almost as concealed was this as a matter
of fact I was asking well for a long
time about you bet one of the guys
saying could you guys just like could
you make a ppq subcompact because it's
so easy to shoot it's like it's glued to
your hand and they just did they're not
in stores everywhere so if you have a
dealer near you again Walters supported
us they're a company with balls so at a
certain point listen sig is great clock
is Drake's are you picking BMW picking
Mercedes you pick and Porsche is a
matter of preference I like the wall
Thor personally I think it's better than
any other firearm out that's we went
after them as a sponsor and they've
supported this show and they haven't
backed down in times when people have
encouraged them to so just go to your
local dealer tell them you want to try
the Walter or local gun range yeah a lot
of times they have them available to
shoot really excited this if you only
get one a lot of people out there say if
I'm only get one right now I can only
afford one I would say well get their
new one hands down the ppq subcompact
cuz you get the best of both worlds and
that's really what it's all about
lahter with Crowder studios is protected
exclusively by Walther and hopper
[Music]
all right our next guest this is the man
we love him on the shows one of our
favorite guests he put heat when he was
there he put the P iymp back in
conservative element love him I wish we
had him when I was in Canada
parliamentary system mr. Nigel Faraj
thank you bring with us sir thank you
good to be here again yeah well yeah you
sound so enthusiastic we're off areas I
said can you hear me mr. fried you said
yeah I don't envy you at all at CPAC I'm
sure everyone wants your time you're
like the only guy there who could
probably throw a good party
is there an after party with a Nigel for
us somewhere going on oh you bet your
life there is in fact to be honest with
you the last 25 years of my life spin a
party stickers whilst I because you know
whilst I've been serious about my
politics and taking on the establishment
I'm worried and what are they to be
changed yeah you know something if it's
not fun doing it it's not worth doing
that's a good point I do love that life
philosophy so let's ask that what kind
of fun are you having at CPAC what are
you doing there what's Nigel's for us
bringing as a message
well the real message I'm bringing is
please please America do not judge my
country and my people by the Mayor of
London Sadiq Khan and by Jeremy Corbyn
the Marxist leader of the Labour Party
because what we've got here we've got
the left in Britain being constantly
abusive about Trump about America saying
that if the president comes to visit our
country they'll organize mass protests
and actually that is not the view of
most British people you know president
Trump's popularity his ratings are going
up in the UK and indeed around the world
and he's been to Paris he's been to
Brussels he's been to Rome he's been all
over the world and particularly given
that America is the biggest investor in
the UK the UK is the biggest investor in
America not to mention the fact that
president Trump's mother was Scottish we
want Trump to come to the UK and let's
sit down and start talking about trade
as soon as we possibly can that explains
that we went to Ireland we broadcast
from Ireland there was a drunken
Scotsman there drinking Budweiser who
will hit the sensor button but he came
in we were talking with these Irish
people
time who did not sit they said they
didn't like Trump but they agree with
his policies it's one guy came in he was
Scottish and the live stream with the
sky every party yeah what would you say
would be like it can't be reflected in
statistics because every Brit I talk
with they go yeah listen I mean Trump
you says some stuff and I wish he
stopped tweeting but we wish we had
someone like him here we're really not
that anti Trump it's not reflected in
statistics though because people often
when polled say no no no I'm not on
board with President Donald Trump would
you say it's a plurality of people in
the UK would you say it's 50/50 oh look
you know for many many times over the
last 30 months or so I've wondered
whether I was the only President Trump
supporter in the entire United Kingdom
basis because because even the
Conservative Party the so-called
Conservative Party in Britain
you know never have a nice word to say
about him but what I've noticed what
I've noticed over the course of the last
few months and particularly with Trump's
overseas trips and overseas speeches you
know take Davos just a few weeks ago is
I think I think what people are saying
is look for the British they find Trump
a bit brash they find him a bit kind of
loud a bit out there a bit if I dare say
it New York yes yes I mean you know
that's who he is and it's a kind of a
style of politics that we're not really
used to but what I'm now getting from
people in the UK is they're beginning to
say you know what we're beginning to
understand it we're beginning to get it
here we've got a president who is
pro-business here we got a president who
was deregulating here we got a president
who's put through some massive tax cuts
and here we got a president that spreads
optimism compare that right to the
leader of Germany Angela Merkel I mean
if you're feeling down
just watch Merkel on television you feel
that miracle can get out conservative
maybe you can set us straight on Europe
how does that pass through the filter
Merkel concern well I think the truth of
it is that most conservative parties in
Europe have come
lately surrendered over the last quarter
of a century right they become they
become Center passes and the liberal
parties and mild socialist parties have
become hard left Europe itself has
shifted considerably to the left and a
lot of that to do with the influence and
power of the European Union and that's
why what you've got is the fight back
and in many ways brexit was the first
example you've seen of that fight back
you know that phenomenon crossed over
here with Trump winning and now what
you've got you've got the traditional
mainstream passes moving to the left and
moving down in the opinion polls and
you've got new challenger passes quite a
lot on the center-right we're now
gaining in ground European politics is
changing very quickly and I can tell you
this that the revolt of 2016 is still
rolling absolutely insane it's like in
Canada in Quebec where I was from we had
liberal socialist and liberal socialist
separatists there were no concern but
you know it's interesting you bring it
up because I know if you know this I
know you've gotten into it with him
Russell Brand is back to podcasting okay
I know you and him have butted heads a
few times and modern-day Che Guevara
whatever he is exactly give me the you
mean they find him in South America with
a rifle that was never fired saying I
worth more to you alive than dead and
you see his cowardice do you think I
have to be careful because I would like
to him to be I would like him to be on
the show but he is a man obviously huge
celebrity in the UK then then carried
its stateside and it's fascinating to me
on his YouTube channel right now is he
worried does this show no one watches it
except two episodes that included
conservative guests and this is
something I find in him because I know
he talked to you very disrespectfully
about you know your rhetoric and he
talks constantly was talking with Jordan
Peterson about you know the mainstream
media and the corporate elite these are
the people you can't make fun of love
and I'm said they're gonna want a second
how many hundreds of millions of dollars
were spent creating this brand that has
Russell Brand from MTV from Viacom from
Universal Studios the media supported
him didn't support you and he acts as
though you were a part of the mainstream
media establishment and he was rebelling
against you but now on equal footing
people don't watch him without the
hundreds of millions have you seen that
shift to cultural yeah oh look
one thing I've noticed in the European
Parliament but if the pro EU politicians
want to get lots of hits on YouTube
they've got to criticize and condemn me
and then they get loads and loads of hit
exist because people are bored with them
and bored with what they have to say and
I think your analysis is quite right
actually with the agenda he's promoting
whatever Russell Brand says he's
actually campaigning for Goldman Sachs
and for the big multinationals and for
this undemocratic former government
based in Brussels that is called
European Union and a form of government
that if Hillary Clinton had become your
president she wanted you to be part of
as well so thank God for what happened
on November the 8th 2016 oh absolutely
and thank God for paving the way with
brexit if Hillary Clinton were president
Russell Brand would probably burn her
advisory can you imagine me up at night
but we do what we would love to have him
on the show Russell Brent I know you
were busy mr. fraud you have anything
specific to plug so Nigel underscore
Faraj on Twitter we love following you
we love what you've been doing and
please stay safe and have fun partying
at CPAC thanks for making the time good
sir I sure will thank you very much guys
thank you god bless we back
[Music]
the media says we gotta listen to the
kids who are currently eating tied pots
just for fun
children don't know anything why would
we listen to them about guns
if you have balls with no hair I will
not care what you say to
why are we listening to children are
people crazy
co-op thinks we should listen to the
kids if it is important
but the left always says you can kill
them if your mom is pregnant and not
really feeling it if you've never worked
a job or had a broken heart if you can't
buy smokes at a quicky Mart I will not
listen to what you say to me
why are we listening to children are
crazy children are great but they don't
know anything you're supposed to be
protected by adults like us with things
like guns have a great day
[Music]
this is the widest dance the worst
come on we are yeah it's like if Steve
Jobs did a PBS special to teach kids
about hip-hop you to track yes exactly
oh gosh I forgot about the u2 tracks I
called like five people that day going
dude someone hacked my phone why do I
would never have u2 on my phone right
you follow our next guest on the twitter
at stefan molyneux youtube.com slash
free domain radio his new book well not
new the art of the argument and calm we
did a whole series a couple of mock
debates so you can never read that
stefan molyneux how are you sir I'm very
well how you doing I am doing okay now
is this is this is that the Chinese
collar there your look no okay
just tall black so I can't see the
contrast now just straight up collar I
thought you were just doing this
starting to get into Eastern mysticism
or some little culture I always when a
professor comes in and they choose the
Chinese collar you're like come on I'm
gonna get a Marxist boot print on your
ideological foreheads that's biased you
mean it's what's funny seeded dress
first a shot and his one of his
documentaries is like oh here comes the
mouth yes exactly
I had a professor that was actually I'm
not a professor drama teacher in high
school her name was mrs. Jean drew she
actually was a great drama teacher she
knew a lot I learned a lot about sort of
a controlling your body acting on stage
combat but she won point when she was
paid over what we were arguing about I
think was maybe Native Americans and I
just said something and she said oh
that's so right-wing I was 12 and I went
home and I said dad what is this she did
yelled at me that was right-wing that's
how I learned it was from my Asian not
my Asian collared drama teacher
missile show procreation which segues
nicely into a conversation this civility
of the left at 12 years old my drama
teacher was berating me have you been
this week Stefan well I have been
enjoying watching your interactions with
some lovely leftist open-minded people
who love reason and evidence on campus
and this is the thing that to me is I
don't I'm not left-wing I'm not
right-wing but I do enjoy spending time
with people who don't call me Satan for
having different perspectives opinions
facts reason evidence day
one of the great challenges like it has
become like the religious warfare that
that plagued Europe for a couple of
hundred years
it's where the difference of opinion is
not a difference in interpretation it's
not a difference in source data it's not
a difference in reasoning good or bad it
is good versus evil to disagree with me
as evil and that is fundamentally a
fragmented holy horror of Christendom
when you had the you know and Baptists
warring with this wingait lian's warring
with the you know other Protestants and
the Calvinists and so on and everybody
was trying to kill each other for 300
years because to disagree was evil and
it's like it's so weird to me that the
largely secular and atheist left is
manifesting some of the worst and most
deplorable habits of extreme
fundamentalist religiosity well all the
client at I'm claiming to be rational in
secular first off I appreciate you
attempting to re-appropriate the term
deplorable I see how you fit that in
there secondly if you don't wanna refer
to a saint and unfortunately have the
gray patch that grows in this way you're
gonna have to die that thirdly no I
think you're absolutely correct and you
know it's it's here's something else too
I'll talk about this later in the
program to disagree is evil but acts of
evil as we just saw in Florida blamed on
inanimate objects there is a fundamental
in capability of accepting that evil
exists and acknowledging it for what it
is when it's clear when we should all
agree hey listen someone mass murdering
people that is evil no no no at that
point it's just it's it's maybe mental
illness it's about the gun laws no no
let's talk about it from evil first and
then let's move on but when it comes to
disagreeing for example male privilege
is a myth well that's evil and that's
what I find so crazy about it would be
one thing if they just refused to
acknowledge the concept of good and evil
all around but they don't oh man these
people use the debt more than you do
magicians because what they do is if
people had done their job you know do
your damn job and we can have our
freedoms right if the FBI had done their
job after being repeatedly warned about
this guy I was just reading this morning
that one of the families he was staying
with told the cops oh this guy had guns
to people's head if they had done the
jobs the police had been called 39 times
to his house right because of elder
abuse or child abuse because of like
random ha
verbal stuff that was going on there was
ample warning there was if those laws
had been enforced if he's shooting a gun
in the neighborhood blowing up chickens
with his gun if that law had been
enforced this guy would have been off
the streets right so the fact that the
police doesn't do their job that the
police don't do their job the fact that
the FBI don't do their job the fact that
16 Child Services was called and should
have been doing their job the fact that
16 different bureaucratic layers didn't
do their job well that means you lose
your fundamental rights to own a gun
come on if the government can't do its
job they will do a terrible job of
restricting gun ownership anyway so why
should one series and layers of
government incompetence lead to another
stripping of Rights no just have them do
their jobs and we won't have these
problems up it sounds to me like Stefan
Molyneux doesn't care about children
okay that's what it sounds like to me
mr. Satan's on your hands mr. Shane has
blood in his waitwait the mosque slips
of course it's all a front for 51 years
it's been a front Laila lay low for 51
years and then just come out a little
more no it really is a long ball Kahn
let me tell you yes exactly I will
appreciate your commitment to character
Daniel day-lewis could learn a thing or
two
it is remark or sigh think you answered
your own question they don't want to
acknowledge the fundamental incompetence
of government and of course they have a
penchant for stripping people of actual
fundamental human rights like that of
self-preservation and I will say this
listen you know people talk about
disagreeing I've disagreed with some
people on the right in the sense that a
lot of them go too far and say well oh
we have it's a mental health issue no no
it's a violent past issue it's a past of
violent transgressions because we don't
want the the government table to say
well you know what you uh you took xanax
as a teenager you can't purchase a
firearm now I know plenty of people who
have mental health season one thing too
I don't want people out there to not
pursue mental health assistance for fear
of losing their rights that's something
that's lost and I know the right is
looking to counter the left and so they
sort of simplify it well on a second
let's look at this person like you said
thirty nine notifications including
violent actions and by the way this is
all this should all be on a background
check just just got my new Walther
background check ask you any felonies
any violent misdemeanors or domestic
abuse it's just it just wasn't reported
this is why I like Trump you just
sidesteps all of it just goes under bump
stocks yeah
Bob stock because belt loops is too hard
to say so here's the funny thing too I
don't like this mental illness stuff too
because mental illness let's just say
it's a little bit of a fluid term I mean
any psychologists and psychiatrists out
there who think that Trump is mentally
ill right and would love to take away
his rights how many boys stuck in
terrible girl centric schools with
really biased anti-boy female teachers a
lot of time and that bias has been very
clearly recorded it's like oh you have
mental illness you missed you must out
now take amphetamines because you're not
fitting into a terrible school that
hates you for being male and it's like
right I don't know I don't it's such a
slippery definition what is mental
health I mean under the Soviet Union you
were mentally ill if you didn't love
communism clearly in theory I have
what's tranquilizers shoved up your nose
because you weren't adapting or your
environment yes yeah yeah it's way too
to the freest term like Oh having having
trouble taking away people's rights well
we'll just slap an arbitrary label
called mental illness on them and next
you know when the problem is the right
concedes that ground because they want
to stand a constitutional in a second
amendment as they should yeah yeah on
mental illness no no ha a second we want
people to be mentally healthy we want
people to get help if they need help and
we don't want them to be afraid to do
that for fear of losing their rights
like you said I mean I have family
members who lost two parents very
quickly and someone prescribed them
antidepressants now that's a bad doctor
you know it doesn't mean that this
person is bipolar certainly not with
comorbidity does that prevent them from
being able to ever defend themselves
this is something that a lot of people
throw out and they try and act as though
it's common ground like oh yeah let's
agree mentally ill people it's not okay
to say hashtag not all Muslims what then
hashtag all mentally ill people there's
a pinon spectrum as it were and also
many people who claim to be on the
spectrum who really aren't maybe that's
the silver lining there people stop
claiming to be on a spectrum like I have
Asperger's well now you can't buy it
[Laughter]
well here's the thing too everyone
should understand this that mental
health is going to become the new Nazi
cuz you know how that game worked over
the last couple of years yeah you hate
Nazis yeah yeah Nazis are bad
yeah I hate Nazis too Nazis are the
worst you agree with me yeah yeah Nazis
are the worst psyche you're a Nazi you
don't want that so it's gonna be like
yeah mentally ill people shouldn't have
guns okay I'll take that argument is
fine right Oh everyone on the right is
mentally ill no guns for like you know
how this definition works they get you
to agree but the worst thing around and
then they expand that definition to
include everyone except themselves that
is an old con that's been going on since
the French Revolution yeah exactly
that's a good point in going and people
people say oh that doesn't happen it can
happen very very quickly and it's also
why I don't want President Trump or his
administration to have the ability to
determine that just as I wouldn't want
Barack Obama's administration I want the
guy in office who doesn't want the job
who wants to do as little as humanly
possible this needs your reaction and by
the way this is why this happens right
in the states I know up there in Canada
you guys don't have the rights of
protecting yourself unfortunately use a
Lego gun and instill fear in a criminal
and all of a sudden you guys can be
charged it's pretty high in Canada man
it's a rifle less than fully informed of
that but anyway go on no well not in
Quebec where I was from and Quebec it
was insanely difficult we knew one
person ever growing up who had a handgun
it was like oh my god it's in the
magical mystery yeah but but they'd
speak French so this is true this is
true all right and we're still smarting
over the French Revolution so clearly it
takes a little while to get over that
jumpiness regarding all of that that's
true and we can classify the French is
mentally ill certainly French Canadians
on the spectrum but yeah no it is
remarkable that this is they jump they
pounce right now because it is a wildly
unpopular issue I don't know if you saw
the Young Turks I thought it was
hysterical that they put out do you
support an assault weapons ban and 83%
of their audience said no this is their
chance they have to politicize and we
were just talking about this earlier
listen kid everyone has a right to speak
doesn't necessarily mean you have a
right to be heard by everybody but it
also just shouldn't determine policy I
don't know how that's controversial you
don't care about kids I don't care about
kids I don't trust them on a lot of
things certainly not when it comes to
determining my right but not to make
chocolate milk yesterday think in
foreign policy today I don't think so I
don't think so
so Stefan though the question to you is
why don't you care about children well
this comes down to this question of root
causes and I always find that the left
loves to play whack-a-mole with effects
which ends up with your rights being
whacked away right and they refuse to
deal with root causes because a lot of
times the root causes
are people who vote for the left so what
are some of the root causes around
school shootings well one thing that's
in common off the entire list I think it
was 26 people that CNN put out of school
shooters or that only one of those 26
school shooters have been raised from
birth by his biological father who maybe
we found something that might be a bit
of a clue which is fatherlessness maybe
a lot of these kids of course are on
these psychotropic sits SSRIs these
mind-altering substances which have
labels about how dangerous they can be
in terms of suicidality homicide
allottee uncontrollable rage and so on
we've got these kinds of issues and
we've got alienation within
neighborhoods neighborhoods fragmenting
to some degree due to diversity a loss
of neighborhood trust the lost of
community trust the schools are getting
worse and worse and bullying is a big
huge problem in schools that
administrators rarely ever deal with
effectively you got families fragmenting
all over the place you've got a sense of
nihilism because P kids know how much
they're being born into like hundred
thousand dollars worth of debt just to
be born 1.7 million dollars worth of
unfunded liabilities there's a lot of
root causes and root problems to do with
this but the left doesn't want to deal
with that right because the left wants
to fragment the family so they don't
ever want to point out to the negative
effects of fragmenting the family the
left loves single moms cuz single moms
vote for the left they vote for big
government because they're not out there
in the marketplace for the most part
they're sucking up government goodies
yeah so the left doesn't want to
alienate their base but unfortunately
it's a lot of their base that's
contributing to this stuff so then they
make it a right-wing issue to take away
guns because they don't want to deal
with the root cause as they've supported
for the last 50 years and I think listen
we do have to get going here but I think
you boil it down that root cause the
main cause before anything else like you
said aside from one is fatherlessness
and that's we can get to correlation
causation people go well they're on
these antidepressant these new well a
lot of them are because they're mentally
disturbed because they weren't raised
with a father so before you get to the
down the trail boom like you said from
birth no dad we've talked about that it
determines whether you're likely to
graduate from high school go to college
have a successful marriage have
successful relationships have healthy
relationships go to college end up in
prison all of these things is daddy in
the home thank you daddy for coming by
that is stefan molyneux the art of the
argument dot-com
we appreciate you sir but again if you
don't want the Satan label
the beer maybe I do maybe I don't we'll
leave that in the maybe viewer
discretion is advised
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
dumbest cops is filmed on location with
the brave strong women of law
enforcement
all suspects are innocent until proven
guilty in a court of law
yeah do you know how fast you're going
there sir I know I'm sorry don't jeez do
that it went on the force these days
excuse me
I met the PT requirement I did a
30-second dead hang ok I'm sorry just
you're really small but I mean you're
very pretty
watch it I can do 40 push-ups are those
male push-ups or girl push-ups
it is 2018 you Pig I can't believe you
asked me that are you a natural brunette
are you a natural jerk okay that is it
I'm gonna go get my supervisor the
supervisor male or female oh you wait
here you just wait here
[Music]
don't know why actually all my breath oh
god L feel I could act the whole thing
healthy to do it's funny you know
yesterday's show for those who aren't
mug club members who had a full show of
course we do a full show every day level
code I come / mug club and I was I was
exhausted even though I had slept more
last night two hours of sleep feel fine
I guess cross-eyed RuPaul oh hell they
go back I don't know thank you so much
as Stefan Milan and of course Nigel for
us next week we have I know you have Jim
Norton Paul Joseph Watson Chuck Woolery
David Barton and oh the lady uh Maria
del Rosso who really disagree with me
feminists who really did not like my
change in my mind that's one thing
that's pretty funny to me that changed
my mind segment that we did there were a
bunch of articles out there and we'll
call everyone out by name soon enough so
if that's okay well invite them all on
the show to come on one by one they'll
get 30 minutes each but everyone wrote
about the tweet it's a picture or just
came kind of a meme and something were
pretty funny but they never showed the
video no Steven did this man steven
crowder who's o far-right troll decided
to get people upset about on campus
about male privilege and he got his
dragged across the internet was that
what happened roll the tape I decline
with the pro-gun we're gonna do another
one of those by the way member they were
like I can t believe he just went he
just tried to get a rise out of students
did you watch the our video or we said
that on top of students isn't on ik now
where they go it's time to have a
conversation that's all we do all we do
is have a conversation constantly
constantly an open invitation to most
people of course there's some exceptions
are gonna be one guy with an egg profile
on his Twitter right now to followers
[Music]
but conversations full-time but like
it's novel to the left right now well
they hate it I mean that's why they try
to shut down so fast maybe their their
little feminist gender studies
professors creating a safe space so yeah
that's another thing from your word
talks about male privilege articles out
there saying it was an example of male
privilege that Steven Carter is able to
set up a tent on campus really really
it's male privilege that we had
secured a permit set up a table
ourselves get assaulted sometimes and
often get kicked off despite getting the
proper paperwork
anyway that's male privilege alright I
think you've you've conceded some some
ground bail privilege sucks um so we
have a lot going on next week I think
one thing that's really lost and I was
you know up last night as a big reason I
couldn't sleep we talked about this last
week where you line up on rights but I
think something that we were just
touching this was stefan molyneux
something lost in all of this this the
new dialogue having a conversation as
you see was CNN in the town hall and
everyone talking about gun control and
mental illness and and maybe it's the
medication and we're losing sight of
something fundamental and that's written
small equivalency of violence it really
doesn't make violence there they are not
morally equivalent what Stephen Wilford
did with his ar-15 there is no moral
equivalence to what this horrible person
who we won't even name on the show
didn't Florida that's not to me here
people talking about a lot when you just
blame me an animate object when you
blame the pill not only do you lose
sight of what evil is but you're doing a
fundamental to service to young
Americans teaching them that all
violence is equal that's the problem
I've always had with no tolerance
policies in school a bully could be
beaten on you this is what it was at
Centennial high school and you shove him
off and you both get suspended you'd
both get the same sentence you know um
there's a film out there right now I was
talking about with bas Rutten this week
called ice guardians I think on Netflix
and I talked about hockey enforcers and
we have some some good family friends
who were enforcers in the NHL so this is
this is um has been going on they try to
get rid of fighting in hockey for a long
time and something they've realized
actually there are more concussions only
5% of concussions in hockey came from
the enforcers right Sidney Crosby now
has had more concussions and more
injuries he's the best player in the NHL
for those who don't follow in one season
than Wayne Gretzky had his whole career
why because of Semenko because I'm Marty
McSorley fact then he wouldn't be traded
without Marty McSorley who was enforcer
now what was Marty McSorley his job just
to be violent pretty much he was a good
hockey player but it was you rough up
Wayne Gretzky he hurts you why because
there were bad people on the ice sheet
players often Swedes
as Don cherry says Swedes cheapest
players there are on the bench they
would cheap shot Wayne Gretzky because
they'll take a five-minute penalty
they'll take a fine what they won't take
is a beating from semanko or beating
from Marty McSorley and the media what
they used to do they did this with
hockey we follow this a-hole a long time
my dad's a big hockey guy of course in
Canada um they would show someone taking
a cheap shot like cross-checking or
elbowing a guy in the face and go look
we need to remove the violence in hockey
but those were never the enforcers the
people who did that were always the
cowards and you see more of them now
because there's no there's no
retribution there's no accountability
sure
so in removing accountability it's the
point here is that guy elbowing that guy
cross-checking that is an immoral person
willing to commit an act of violence and
he's going to take the fine he's gonna
take the five-minute penalty the only
way to stop that person that person's
amoral evil violent action is with an
equally virtuous violent action violence
never solves problems now sometimes it
does solve problems the boy responsible
for this shooting committed an act of
evil okay an evil deed through a violent
act it is about the action and the
intent behind the action it's not just
about the object it's not just about the
upbringing it is about his actions your
actions defined you and in this case the
motive matters that's why we have laws
that's why there's murder first degree
there's manslaughter which sounds far
worse but it's actually far less we put
in the gun we blame mental health we
don't want to blame our moral
shortcomings we don't want to examine
evil and the truth is there can be
virtuous violence and there can just as
surely there can be peaceable evil
violence was used to liberate us as a
country and deliberate others from
slavery let me ask you this when we're
talking about violence if you really
thought about evil good evil good
violence peace what's more virtuous
violent liberation of slaves or
peacefully submitting to enslavement
violent protection of your women and
children or peaceful surrender of them
to evil men I think a lot of people
they're pointing the proactive evil
violence and they blame the utility
because it allows us all to avoid are
passive acts of evil every day
particularly particularly in the media
you commit media particularly
entertainment industry we know this very
very peaceful very peaceably you commit
acts of evil when you don't blow the
whistle on systemic sexual assault for
pedophilia you commit evil when you look
away when a man is abusing his wife as
happens rampantly in Hollywood some of
you commit evil when you look away when
some other man is abusing your
life like every single man who knew what
was happening with Harvey Weinstein you
commit evil very peaceably every day
when you turn away from someone being
hurt we all do it or from someone in
need but it's an evil that only you know
because you're evil the evil isn't it's
in me work we all have evil in us this
goes back to the fundamental question
that Dennis Prager talks about your evil
I'm evil it is in us but truly evil
people
everyone has evil in them but evil
people people who allow it to overtake
them will do anything to avoid looking
in that mirror they want to blue that
they're essentially good that's the big
irony evil people believe they're
essentially good generally speaking good
people acknowledge that they could
become evil people bad people
essentially believe they're good even
though their actions speak otherwise so
where they do people in the tool don't
want to look at me don't show me the
mirror it's there if it's the ar-15 it's
the bomb stock it's the Second Amendment
it can't be me you know I read a grid
again recently um we were doing some
research I think was Sean Penn and he
talked about destroying all of his guns
one of his girlfriends I think maybe
took him and turn him in some art piece
and he said it was I realized it was
time to to destroy all these cowardly
killing machines
really cowardly guns have souls now Sean
Penn maybe you're a coward really Sean
what about a woman home alone and a
rapist breaks and is she cowardly to
want to protect herself these are the
talking points oh man man with a gun
little dick what about a woman take
yourself from right man trying to get in
coward get an alarm system doesn't have
the money for it now he's in the house
get a dog she's allergic he's up the
stairs because you're an evil prick she
can't have a cowardly killing machine to
stop from being forcibly raped a lot of
people are blaming the ar-15 as we know
many of them have never touched one
alive - bibliography of time they're not
afraid of it it's something it's really
afraid of the air 15 that's something -
a lot of conservative rude no not afraid
of it they're afraid of evil they're
probably afraid of themselves a little
bit they should be what would they do
with an ar-15
how would they wield that power most
people aren't afraid of being powerless
I don't know where this quote comes from
I think it was I don't know who said it
and I don't want to be I don't want to
be quoted as misquote and say exactly
I'll tribute to Nakia most people are
not afraid of being powerless they're
afraid of being granted powers they're
afraid of being more
powerful neighborhoods that's what most
people willingly give up power everyday
people willingly give up their power
every day to their employees or their
government just just give me my
nine-to-five
I'll take security over freedom just
take the taxes and take care of my
retirement I don't have to make my own
decisions
they give over power all the time so
what would these people what wouldn't
many Americans who've never touched when
what would they do with that killing
machine would they save lives like
Stephen Wilford would they take them
that's the ultimate question that we're
asking here that's where people line up
on this issue that's what determines how
you answer this fundamental question
because throughout history humans have
virtuously and violently both save lives
and throughout history we've peaceably
passively signed death warrants for
millions of innocent people peacefully
mind you this conversation is about bump
stock it's not about ar-15 it's not
about Zoloft it's not about the
potential of what an ar-15 could do it's
not about the potential of what
modification someone could make to a gun
it's about the potential of evil in
every single human being and how to
safeguard against it and that's what it
comes down to you do you believe like we
taught the hockey enforcer now is you to
bring it back around do you believe that
human beings inherently have an evil
strain in them not all people are evil
not all people are good most people have
some of both do you believe that is that
reasonable point find common ground do
you believe that most people have some
of both in them that yin and yang good
and evil and do you believe that that
evil can warp and grow out of control
you leave every single human being is
capable of evil how do we safeguard
against it do you believe it the only
way to safeguard against people who are
willing to cheap-shot who are willing to
commit massive acts of violent evil or
other people willing to commit acts of
virtuous violence or do you want to be
the person who just peaceably surrenders
your rights who peaceably commits an
active/passive
evil by looking away that's a decision
you have to make that's what this
conversation is really about think about
it talk to you next week
[Music]